okay extremely surprising and weird news
prosecutors have dropped charges against
actor jussie Smollett for the homophobic
hate crime that he was accused of having
staged I'll catch you up if you haven't
followed the story it's a very
interesting and disturbing story we
covered it at the sort of beginning
actor jussie Smollett claimed to have
been attacked by two white men and later
as the details started to sort of fall
apart including that Smollett had been
on the phone with the alleged attackers
hours before the incident he was
arrested and he was charged with
multiple felonies related to staging the
attack falsely reporting crimes and it
looked really really bad prosecutors
said at first that Smollett who was
black and gay arranged for these two men
that he knew to attack him on the basis
that they were anti black anti-gay and I
guess Trump supporters I think there was
like a make America great some kind of
Magha thing involved in the attacks as
well and it seemed really clear that
that's what had happened that this had
been a staged fake hate crime what we
learned yesterday is that prosecutors
have abruptly dropped the charges in
exchange for letting the city keep small
it's ten thousand dollars in bail and
doing some community service which
according to one report he may have
already done or is about to do
Smollett is insisting I guess that he
really was attacked that the story as he
initially told it was accurate and
prosecutors have not been clear about
why they have all of a sudden abandoned
this case we heard from a spokeswoman
for the Cook County Prosecutor's Office
who said that they made the decision to
dismiss the case after quote reviewing
all of the facts and circumstances of
the case we had 16 felony counts here
but the most important thing I think in
interpreting what happened is that this
is sort of a deal okay this is not he
didn't do anything period this is a deal
to drop the charges in exchange for
Smollett a green
let the city keep his bail and doing
community service these are not
significant penalties I'm being clear
about that but he now gets to claim that
he told the truth all along but this is
a deal that was reached and that is not
being fully reported by some of the
media outlets that are talking about
this Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel says
this is a quote whitewash of justice and
is not pleased attorneys don't
understand what's going on again they
say this is a deal of some kind normally
you would include in such a deal that
small it apologizes for what he did or
something like that but that is not what
is going on here and it was considered
that prosecutors even knew why Smollett
allegedly staged this attack he felt he
was underpaid on the show Empire on
which he acts he felt that if he staged
this anti-gay racist attack on himself
he would ultimately get more money from
the people who employ him at Empire and
every thing about this Pat is absolutely
bizarre and I would also add if he now
is maintaining that the attack was real
what's going on with the search for the
perpetrators yeah this story was weird
from the get-go and it's just gotten
even weirder I guess because prosecutors
have decided to drop drop the charges
now you have to reconsider whether or
not he did staged the attack I mean
there would be a lot to answer then like
did he actually pay the two perpetrators
two supposed perpetrators how come those
supposed perpetrators were connected to
the show Empire like I mean all signs
point to him staging the attack still
but just the sudden drop of charges it's
it's totally weird and the fact that
he's able to stay indignant about it
that he doesn't have to apologize that
he doesn't have to admit guilt in
exchange for the deal very weird it may
come down to the charges were dropped
because he has really good high-priced
attorneys that a lot of people can't
afford and they were able to make this
happen
practical question is what happens to
his role on Empire now does he get it
back I don't really care I've never seen
the show but if the reason for the
firing was that he staged the crime
now that he no longer has to admit to
that or is not going to be prosecuted
for that does he then get the job back
because the pretense of the firing has
now been cancelled out I don't know and
it's extraordinarily unusual stuff one
of the days sponsors is privacy calm /
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link